antoine bonjour alors le gilet jaune
valenciennois manu quan avait reçu en
plein visage une grenade lacrymogène
tirée par un cougar le 7 novembre 2019
et il avait perdu un oeil
vous êtes allé le rencontrer chez lui
pour lui demander où en étais ses
démarches de justice et sa santé alors
qu'est ce qu'il vous a répondu
bonjour oui alors ma nuque one il est
très fortement impactée au plan
psychologique parce qu'il lui est arrivé
il dit avoir perdu beaucoup de sa joie
de vivre le plus supporté de se voir
dans un miroir
il a enchaîné les opérations
chirurgicales pour reconstruire le
plancher orbital de son oeil et sa
paupière et il nous a dit son amertume
vis-à-vis de la lenteur du temps
judiciaire
j'ai l'impression que la justice a le
trac beaucoup les beaucoup de l'épier
conseiller il s'agit des jeunes je
comprends pas qu'il ya jamais eu un mot
du gouvernement où les grands
responsables
justement pour toutes ces victimes au
contraire c'est qu'ils disent est plutôt
inverse en disant que c'était nous qui
cherchions
ce qui est leur arrivée c'était limite
de notre faute de quoi un gain à dommage
collatéral qui avait porté plainte
contre le préfet de police de paris
didier lallement contre le tireur et
contre l'état où est ce que oui ou on
est son affaire aujourd'hui antoine
alors pour ce qui est de la justice pour
le moment un juge d'instruction lui a
fait savoir qu'il devra obtenir au moins
un jugement au cours de l'année si manu
quan n'a pas souhaité collaborer avec
l'igpn dont il réfute la légitimité
l'inspection a tout de même rendu ses
conclusions des enquêtes et séverine sa
fiancée donc qui est toujours à ses
côtés dans ces combats et qui font tout
ensemble m'a dit au téléphone qu'il
avait été reconnu comme victime de
violences donc il se pourrait que son
dossier évolue dans un sens favorable
d'un point de vue justice mais l'envié
reste à jamais marquée par cette
mutilation
merci beaucoup antoine une enquête à
retrouver sur notre site rtl france pour
un tv et puis on vous retrouve demain
pour la suite de cette enquête